("The Simpsons Theme" by Danny Elfman)
♪ The Simpsons ♪
- [Narrator] The Simpsons,
it's the longest running
animated show with maybe the most
recognizable character on TV.
- Doh.
Why you little!
Mmm, beer.
- [Narrator] Outside of the U.S.,
the show is beloved by millions.
(speaking in foreign language)
And some of the biggest
fans, Latin Americans.
(speaking in foreign language)
In Mexico City, there is one man
responsible for making Homero
Simpson funny in Spanish.
(speaking in foreign language)
(Homer screaming)
(crowd laughing)
- April Fools, ha ha ha ha ha.
(speaking in foreign language)
(crashing)
- This is the most thoughtful
thing anybody ever.
- Sweet merciful crap, my car!
(speaking in foreign language)
(lively quirky music)